what joseph will eventually come to be
known for
isn't a dreamer but a reader of dreams
[Music]
and jacob dwelled in the land of his
father's sojournings
in the land of canaan this is the
lineage of jacob
joseph 17 years old was tending the
flock with his brothers
assisting the son of billah and the sons
of zilpah
the wives of his father and joseph
brought ill report of them to their
father
and israel loved joseph more than all
his sons for he was a child of his old
age
and he made him an ornamented tunic and
his brother saw it was their father
who loved joseph more than all his
brothers and they hated him
and could not speak a kind word to him
my students are often taken aback
because
joseph brought ill report of them to
their father
students often wonder is this just the
youngest brother being a snitch
hold on to that because i think the text
later will start to answer
our question times we think that the
brothers
simply despise joseph because of his
ornamented tunic
but the text sets it up that the
ornamented tunic
is actually a representation of his
favorite status
and joseph dreamed to dream and told it
to his brothers
and they hated him all the more and he
said to them
listen pray to this dream that i dreamed
and look we were binding sheaves in the
field and look
my sheep arose and actually stood up and
look your sheaves drew round
and bowed to my sheaf and his brother
said to him do you mean to reign over us
do you mean to rule us and they hated
him
all the more for his dreams and for his
words
there are a few interesting things going
on here what joseph will eventually come
to be known for
isn't a dreamer but a reader of dreams
here we begin in the in the narrative
we see joseph himself is the dreamer
and he dreamed yet another dream and
recounted it to his brothers and said
look i dreamed to dream again and look
the sun and the moon and the 11 stars
were bowing down to me
and he recounted it to his father and to
his brothers and his father rebuked him
and said
what is this dream that you have dreamed
shall we really come i and your mother
and your brothers to bow down before you
to the ground and his brothers were
jealous of him while his father kept the
thing
in mind and again we do not get his
understanding of this dream it's just
these enigmatic
dreams at this point and his brothers
went to graze their father's flock at
shechem
and israel said to joseph you know your
brothers are pastoring at shechem
come let me send you to them and he said
to him
here i am and he said go pray to see how
your brothers fair and how the flocks
fare
and bring me backward ah now we get to
see
perhaps that which preceded there in
chapter 37
that joseph isn't bringing ill report
just in and of himself
it's his father who's asking him to go
and look
after his brothers to see how the flock
is faring
and of course he goes and he looks to
for his brothers
and they saw him from afar before he
drew near
and they plotted against him to put him
to death
and they said to each other here comes
that dream master
and so now let us kill him and fling him
into one of the pits and we can say
a vicious beast has devoured him and we
shall see what comes of his dreams
i find this moment fascinating one
notice they're all speaking together
each said to each other it's as if
they're speaking in a unified manner
and i find this fascinating because what
you saw in the dream
were all of the sheaves on one side and
joseph there against all the others
and this is going to play out in the
narrative for us all the brothers
united against one brother right who is
in fact
uh the beloved of his father
and reuben heard and came to his rescue
and said we must not take his life
and reuben said to them shed no blood
fling him into this pit in the
wilderness and do not raise a hand
against them
so that reuben might rescue him from
their hands to bring him back to his
father
okay we have to stop here this is i
think this is a really important
detail in the narrative first off you
have to realize reuben is the eldest son
whatever favoritism is being heaped upon
joseph
this really is something that ought to
be going to reuben as firstborn
and so now think about what happens
if reuben's plan comes to fruition what
happens
just think about it all the brothers
over here versus joseph the one over
here
and then they fling him into the pit and
then ruben rescues him
and brings him back to his father so
that reuben can stand there in
solidarity with joseph
his father's beloved son and perhaps get
some of joseph's favoritism
some of the light that shines on joseph
to shine a little bit on reuben who of
course has fallen out of his father's
good graces and it happened when joseph
came to his brothers that they stripped
him of his tunic the ornamented tunic
that he had on him and they took him and
flung him into the pit
and the pit was empty there was no water
in it and they sat down to eat bread and
they raised their eyes and saw and look
a caravan of ishmaelites
was coming bearing gum and baum and
laden on their way down to egypt
and judah said to his brothers what gain
is there if we kill our brothers and
cover up his blood
come let us sell him to the ishmaelites
and our hand will not be against him
for he is our brother our own flesh
and it's important to take note here
that it is in fact judah
is the one who wants to find some sort
of material gain
in selling joseph into slavery just take
note of that because this is going to
become
important uh at the at the end of the
story
and his brothers agreed and they sold
joseph into egypt and reuben came back
to the pit and look
joseph was not in the pit and he rent
his garments and he came back to his
brothers and he said the boy is gone
and i where can i turn and they took
joseph's
tunic and slaughtered a kid and dipped
the tunic in blood
and they sent the ornamented tunic that
and had brought it to their father
saying
this is a beautiful moment recognize
pray
is it your son's tunic or not and he
recognized and he said
it is my son's tunic just think about
this for a moment they're showing this
kind of condensed symbol of their
father's favoritism
right he can see it standing of them
of joseph who's gone but also that that
condensed symbol
of their brother's hatred for him of his
favored status
and jacob rent his clothes and put on
sackcloth around his waist
and mourn for his son many days and all
his sons and all his daughters rose to
console him and he refused to be
consoled and said rather i will go down
to my son
in shale morning. and he came for him
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn